restaurant sales have fallen to their
lowest level in 15 years according to
the National Restaurant Association
which tracks this kind of thing some
owners are finding creative ways to
boost business though as they start to
reopen blad duties shows how they use
everything from costumes to musical
performances to keep customers happy in
rural Maine at 290 Main Street families
can get a discount when they pick up an
order but only if they're dressed for
the weekly costume contest so take it
from me and enjoy tonight out in
Oklahoma City at Hamilton Superettan
lounge owner J maze promotes the kitchen
specials dressed as his alter ego
lobster boy what makes that so good
there's Lobster in it as Virginia
reopened restaurants at 50% capacity The
Inn at little Washington uses mannequins
to make socially distant customers feel
a little less lonely down in Greenville
South Carolina proprietor Mike Fraser
came up with something that's really
struck a chord with the community
musical deliveries for a $10 fee local
musicians who once perform on stage at
Smiley's acoustic café will drop off
your dinner with the serenade on the
side one of the few businesses that's
our employees weren't furloughed they
made more money during the lockdown wow
that's amazing I don't know what a lot
of businesses and especially restaurants
can say the same in New York highly
acclaimed chef Mooney Kim is far from
your average delivery guy I'm fascinated
by this idea of a michelin-starred chef
who is delivering food essentially from
the trunk of his car as an owner I've
done dishes I've clear tables I bartend
it you have to do what you need to do I
just thought that if our customers can't
come to us we have to go to them so we
started delivering delivering
family-style meal kits of upscale dishes
he serves at his award-winning
restaurants thank you very much
were you ever worried about going into a
building or an apartment I'm given the
pandemic I worry for myself I worry for
my stuff and I hope it doesn't become a
habit I hope there's a light at the end
of the tunnel
is this wise it's still not close to
what we do or what we did as a
restaurant but we're doing better than
most and we're lucky we I really
consider myself very lucky for CBS this
morning
vladimir duthiers new york gotta do what
you gotta do Gail but look I love that
piece because it shows all the things
that restaurants are doing to try to
keep us the customers happy but I think
restaurants should know that all of us
out here after seeing the struggles that
that industry has had it reminds us of
how important it is to have in your
neighborhood a place where you can get a
good quick affordable bite to eat and
bring it home to your family it is truly
nourishment it is love it is community
and so it goes both ways for sure and
it's also important Tony to support
those restaurants we look at those
pieces that's why I think it's so
important to look to show pieces like
that look at those pieces and a reminder
to support them but I like what chef
said you do what you need to do while
we're what we're all trying to figure
this out it's a new normal for all of us
we still don't know how it's going to
end but I'd like to think there is light
at the end of the tunnel